it was the first weekend of Coachella
this last weekend and I was not there
was I doing I was getting this sweaty in
this tire painting one wall in my house
Coachella no I tweeted out asking you
guys whose look kept aesthetically
should I recreate and so many of you
said James Charles who is a notable
youtuber makeup guru color ista on the
face extraordinaire I saw his which one
ninja look and I thought that's
interesting and also keeps me from
having to do half of my face so okay
let's do that one a very mortal combat
needs bella thorne and also it's a good
look for him because it keeps him from
actually saying anything that could be
completely problem is okay so I have my
inspiration photo right here why you
should pretty you look like a Siberian
Husky and Lisa Frank and Kim Kardashian
got together do it okay I already have
schmutz on my face from earlier today
which doesn't matter hmm
let's start with the eyes a yellow to
red fireEye over here and then it's got
a green to purple eye happening over
here I used this in my glam and war
tutorial that I tried to follow its
Revlon's color charge
it's the palette that I think when
Stefani I'm creating and begin I've got
a base on chor at this candy Johnson
palette banana cream lamb same size
he's got very very highlighted in her
tear ducts whipped cream color from
candy Johnson's palette this is gonna be
like what people that go to Coachella
experience this video is like really
cool in theory but then doing it is very
just cumbersome and uncomfortable yeah
also has a highlight under his brow
let's start with this yellow to orange
closest thing AB the yellow is this goal
edition color here on this eye oh I got
Brown in there okay okay ah glamour
putting makeup on let's just smash
yellow all over this whole life now it
blends into an orange I'm gonna use
butterscotch oh wow he does under the
eye oh and he didn't bring the right
brush for that and then I'm stuck in
this corner and I don't feel like
getting on this corner doesn't matter
I'm also gonna take this Kylie palette
that all of the names of the shadows
have been
rubbed off middle ones oh man I got this
new brush Wow
I took some butterscotch and sweet
topping from candy Johnson's ballot me
just smash it under my eye so it looked
like I had a very formal and fancy
version of tetanus now we're moving on
to the red burgundy color on the outside
oh it's very Brown I can use lipstick as
eyeshadow because I'm a genius red and
orange lipstick who cares it's Coachella
if I James Charles is like oh my god
grace is the most innovative beauty guru
of the day never know existed oh you're
welcome
try to blend this in as much as we can
close I mean wow identical I mean so
close it's scary okay now let's move on
to the green blue purple [ __ ] stress
level never leaves dude that's the fun
thing about going to music festivals
some greens blues and then find some
purple there's no tiredness Wow taste
the rainbow lick my eyelids done we're
gonna take this makeup wipe and clean
this up a little bit blend it in more
make this I look like shape of water
make this I look like tan mom yeah Wow
look at that
no he just does a bunch of black
eyeliner and eye shadow so let's do that
here we go urban decay they just sent me
a box of eyeliners because they're nice
and they realized the people like me
that are not good at makeup still like
makeup I use the F out of this there we
go
oh there she is Mia Coachella okay
eyeliners on oh now I'm gonna blend it
in do they use blends black eyeliner
until all the work that you previously
did seems to not matter but sticker
makeup wipe and clean that up a little
bit that basically negates everything
we've done previously which is super fun
let's put some liquid liner on
[Music]
Wow yeah it's just that it must be being
James Charles I think is being this
beautiful with some truly stressful
eyebrows we're gonna use this brown ooh
I think I know let's do some fixing up
let's fast forward now let's put some on
my face bronzer whoa weird about lashes
on before we do we're gonna put some
mascara on our eyelashes this is just
the cat mess I mean fun Coachella yay
vibes
okay now we're both lashes on scuse me
while I have a crisis oh yeah I'm like
10 minutes from done I just want to get
your opinion when I'm done oh I'm sorry
I'm my recording stopped automatically
because it's been over a half hour these
eyelashes are on these are ready they're
on okay now I want to tweak for a second
no way by tweaking me most just flailing
arms and going with why what Jules Jules
I found these beats so we're gonna use a
few Wow different lit okay here we go
I don't have a lawyer ton scarf do it
don't do it how does it get it's hard to
stay like that anyone got it
[Music]
there you go there is my James Charles
go cello look transformation let me know
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel because I make videos
consistently in existence so I like that
dollar vacation so you get notified when
they go up so that you can just you know
be part of pieces of art like this other
than that I don't know let's see how
books thinks Hey look
this is a pro-wrestler you want to be
ninja from future oh boy that was that
Coachella ok I did my makeup exactly
like James Charles so does that
Coachella this weekend should I know who
Jim Chuck is this is James Charles Jim
Chuck yep
who do you think he is Jesse may YouTube
kid
yep beautiful yeah Thank You Jimmy see